>> Sally: Hey Dude, how are you?
>> Dude: I'm not doing too well.
I'm trying to figure which device to
use to turn off the gas-o-matic module
and stop Buddy from growing too big.
But I don't know how to choose!
>> Sally: Hmm, well choosing the right
device for your system can be pretty hard.
Why don't we work on this together?
>> Dude: That would be great.
I am just going around in circles here.
>> Sally: Well I'd suggest
that you use a digital device
to turn off the gas-o-matic module
when Buddy got to a certain size.
>> Dude: What's that?
>> Sally: Well let's start with the basics,
all digital devices have inputs and outputs
that are always in one of
two states: either ON or OFF.
People who work with electrical devices
sometimes call the two states HIGH
and LOW because of the high or low voltages
that the devices receive or produce.
Other people think of the two states as
true/false or as the numbers 1 and 0.
It really doesn't matter.
What's important for us is that if you
hook up the output of a digital device
to the gas-o-matic, when the device
produces a high signal, Buddy will inflate.
When the device produces a low
signal, Buddy will stop inflating
and he'll just stay the same size for a while.
>> Dude: That's cool but
why make just two states?
Wouldn't it be cooler to make buddy get
bigger really fast at first and then slowed
down when he's close to full size?
I really don't want to see him
growing out of control like before.
Couldn't we build an even more
interesting system from devices
with more states, like three or even ten?
>> Sally: Those are all really interesting ideas
but here's why two states makes the most sense.
Let's imagine that you're measuring the output
signal from your digital device over time.
Depending on what the input to the
digital device is, the output will switch
between its two possible states ON and OFF.
But of course, this drawing
is actually a bit misleading.
See all digital devices, whether they are
genetic devices or electrical devices,
never produce a signal that is perfectly
ON or perfectly OFF like I've drawn here.
There are always some minor
fluctuations in the signal.
These fluctuations aren't real
changes in state of course.
But sometimes, if the fluctuations are too
big, then they might tell the gas-o-matic
to switch on when you really want it off.
>> Dude: Oh no.
I definitely don't want that.
It took forever to clean up the
lab last time that happened.
So the reason we limit the devices to two states
is because they work better when there's noise?
>> Sally: Exactly!
>> Dude: And you think Buddy's growth is noisy?
>> Sally: Definitely!
He changes a little just when he breathes.
And he can grow and shrink a lot depending on
how much food he has and what's around him.
And sometimes I think he
changes size just to show off...
>> Dude: So it sounds like
digital devices are the way to go!
It will tell the gas-o-matic device to turn
on if Buddy's really growing and turn off
if he's full size, but ignore those
in between size fluctuations he likes
to make...but how big are the
fluctuations that the device will ignore?
How does it know?
>> Sally: Well the device
only knows what we tell it,
and we can split up ON and
OFF the way we choose.
>> Dude: OK then...I'll put
the ON/OFF border here!
>> Sally: Dude, weren't you listening!
If the signal is somewhere near this boundary
and noisy, then the device will from switch
ON to OFF or OFF to ON when
you don't want it to.
Here's what we can do.
Let's call just this small
part the "valid" signals
and leave all this in between
as "invalid" signals.
That way the device won't confuse ON signal
values with OFF signal values so easily.
>> Dude: Aw Sally.
Maybe I'm not getting this at all.
It looks like you just put in two boundaries
and now you've got twice as much trouble.
What's to stop the noise from switching between
valid and invalid signals here AND here?
>> Sally: Dude, I actually think
you've got the hang of this.
Here's the trick that engineers use: make the
valid output ranges smaller than the input!
This way the quality of the output
signal is always better than the quality
of the input signal and even if there is noise
on the input, the digital device will get rid
of it but producing a better output signal.
This trick even has a name: Engineers call
the difference between the valid input
and output ranges the noise margin.
>> Dude: Noise margins.
I like it!
Digital devices sound wicked useful.
But can we really build them out of DNA?
>> Sally: Some have already been
built I can show you how they work
in some cells I've got growing in the lab.
The DNA device you want may be
there already and ready to go.
Do you have some time to come to the lab now?
>> Dude: Can I answer in digital?